and this is the first ELC to sort of
dive back into the story stuff as well I
believe yes so we've got to kind of main
story deals ease and as you say this is
the first one this is Italians one as
hora this is talent and this is actually
happening in parallel with the main
story as well so it's after the kind of
story leaves off with tour them and then
reuniting with him to basically team up
and take down this new threat which are
both these new creatures and these new
elite war Chiefs that sour on sent out
and Italian seems to have a fancy new
haircut he also has a fantastic mullet
yes yeah we can't quite see there but
we're looking forward to that was
Michael palette that was actually
stipulated in my get in the contrary I
get one creative decision and by god I
stood up I will have a moment and then
the be no fear and I was like yeah what
else could we do aesthetically I got a
bunch of questions coming in at both for
Troy and Abed a shadow Mordor waffle boy
2 G 2 asks what kind of new creatures
did you put into the game and head to
the effect gameplay so what other types
of creating new creatures are here oh
yes it is these guys there's the carrier
gas which are really offering the
mounted stealth and probably the other
biggest one there's a wretched grouser
greater the grouchy sort of huge
monstrous kind of alpha predators of
Mordor they've been feasting on the
ghouls and that's kind of done hideous
things to their digestive systems so
they can now projectile vom or great a
cigar so so that's both offers a lot of
challenge to take them down but it's
also a lot of fun when you can ride them
and also your ability to dominate and
create your own army that's now extended
to the the ghouls as well so basically
create your own google army and here we
can see there's some of the new war
chiefs and they've got new skills and
new abilities as well so on some of
these guys and our broadcast is asking
can one walk into the more DLC without
playing the main game or whatever
perhaps as well you can you can just
start this directly as a standalone
story it's going to be pretty tough if
you do just you know there's a certain
that's all part of the fun of the DLC
from our point of view we can sort of
cut loose a little bit on the on the
challenge oven so yeah it would probably
be pretty challenging to dive straight
into so a little bit of a refresher on
the the combat system and stuff is
probably recommended you certainly can
play both of them stand alone sy saira
asks for Michael at the Nemesis system
if you could implement it into any other
game franchise what would it be I
remember the first week that the mordoor
came out and people start playing with
it they were saying or we're gonna see a
lot of this and like 2016 people are
going to start adopting similar systems
into that into their games if there was
any game you've played either in your
past as a younger man or in the bin past
year what would it be Qbert probably
just cute Qbert every time you step on a
snake came back and remember do you bake
I'd love it no difa so every time you
play the game soccer in the Premier
League like you tackle someone really
badly and then like half a season later
they just do you as well that's it's
interesting you say that because that's
really the genesis of the idea for the
system is from sports games everything
we worked on before total war as well
and that notion that in sports games the
commentary you know whether it's madden
or whatever remembers the previous
matches talks about the matchup and when
you play a season you are building a
narrative yeah so when you lose you
don't go ok I'm going to stop and start
again I'm unity and time always moves
forward so that notion of kind of
systemic gameplay and memory and grudges
and kind of individual every character
being individual having their own name
building up their history over time sort
of definitely has something in common
with that but ah ah that's it that's an
interesting question I don't know for
some reason blade runner came into my
head or under nemesis like replicants
would be rinsed out and it's bonding you
shot me in the face real doc be tasks
raw egg is one of the best characters
many gaming groans and is it oh yeah
you're pretty pretty awesome like if you
were fighting yeah cure my knee yeah
just fighting through all the other
shootings at Hogwarts and like the
Nemesis system I could work yeah maybe
first year murder he goes on bible
darkbeat says Rock bags one of his
favorite characters of the year since
every other orc
will we see him let's say in the dlc I
don't want to say anything about 1000
saying editing Oh keep asking people to
print some ratbag little t-shirts you
know sir alright guys we right yeah I
cannot go either way yes certainly I
mean that's that's the power of oh
that's great that's great you're older
of hopefully getting to keep working on
this now is yeah ratbags destiny is
undecided at this point we've got a rat
bag skin you just play everything as red
bag we talked about that a lot as well
it wouldn't it obviously couldn't I
don't think it could really happen
because he would obviously just have to
hook up everything yeah mine too but
some sort of delusional dream that he
was having you know you really could do
a rafic as a dream sequence but you like
to write back the LC props would I like
you oh yeah he wouldn't
you